Republicans are still inching toward a
majority in the house and may end up
being decided by Republicans and even in
the deep blue State of California
ironically look at your screen Mike
Garcia remains ahead in California's
27th district Kevin Kiley is ahead in
California three young Kim and Michelle
Steele are closing in on victories in
Southern California and even prominent
house Democrat Katie Porter is in a
tight race in Orange County remember
Republicans need 218 seats as you can
see we put it on the screen and to win
that house majority which appears they
are headed towards joining us now former
Speaker of the House Newt Gingrich I
mean it's pretty remarkable developments
that uh
Adam laxalton is now an odds on favorite
in Nevada we have a highway now for
Blake Masters based on new numbers we
have more outstanding votes tonight 400
000 of the 650 outstanding our day of
handed in ballots that Blake Masters
have been winning 68 percent of those uh
that's an interesting story tonight and
then the runoff in Georgia State you
know well uh your thoughts on all of it
Newt Gingrich
look this this is I think this is the
wildest election of my entire career as
you know because 1994 was a big night
much further ahead
no I was but I'm just saying I look at
this and and there's so many questions
you know in 2014 when we won uh reince
priebus as the Republican National
committee chairman asked me to develop a
review even though we'd want to try to
figure it out and I think that that uh
Ronald McDaniel the the chair of the RNC
ought to set up a similar Review
Committee there's so many questions that
we need to get answered apparently House
Republicans got five or six million more
votes than Democrats but it didn't
translate into the same comparable
number of seats we need to examine that
apparently some incumbents lost who
shouldn't have we should examine that no
incumbent lost in 2020 with Kevin
McCarthy's leadership and no Republican
loss to 1994 when we took the house so
something there are a lot of things we
have to ask ourselves but I'll tell you
this I talked to Herschel today he is
out there running uh every single game
that went into overtime in his career he
won he sees this exact exactly the same
way I think he's going to win but I
agree with Lindsay everybody who can
help him
ought to go to Team herschel.com and do
so I think that Adam who has worked very
hard is very smart for former Attorney
General of Nevada I think Adam is going
to win I think now that Blake Masters is
going to win and I look I look at what's
happening uh with Carrie Lake she's
going to win we're going to end up by
the time this is over every effort of
the news media to make Republicans feel
bad is going to fall apart and remember
the biggest change in Washington
will be when Nancy Pelosi handles that
gavel over to Kevin McCarthy you go from
a radical liberal to a solid
conservative that is the biggest single
change and my sense from Biden's press
conference yesterday he didn't get any
of it he has no idea what's going on uh
and uh I think they're going to continue
sound down the same disastrous Road
what do you think uh the message what
advice do you give Herschel it's kind of
interesting he never lost again an
overtime game in his life that's not a
record many people can say
you know I don't know if he'll do it but
I told him something I'd learned many
many years ago from a report former
Republican governor of Ohio uh who used
to take his wallet out and put it in the
podium and he said let me tell you what
this race is about
my opponent wants to take money out of
your wallet I want to put money into
your wallet now do you want more money
in your wallet or do you want them
taking it out of your wallet well this
guy won an amazing number of
governorships because people got it the
key race here is simple you have in in
Warnock somebody who is to the left of
Bernie Sanders I mean Warner is
genuinely right at the edge of extreme
socialism and he also has a terrible
record as a landlord where they have
kicked people out of houses for as
little as 26 dollars I mean it's just
really the road story
yeah he talks about character look at
his friends you know Louis Farrakhan and
and Jeremiah Wright and Fidel Castro and
uh and by the way speaking of domestic
violence he was accused of that and he
was arrested for obstructing an
investigation into his Camp a child uh
abuse why do you think Republicans in
the house they're going to get a
majority it appears
um but it's not going to be anywhere
what we thought it was yet they won by
six million more votes according to the
latest numbers how did that that doesn't
add up to me
well that's that's why I think we need a
serious study committee to really stop
and take a look look as you know because
we've talked about many times every
model I believe in failed in this
election and that's why I was very
confident going into election day I'd
spent three days campaigning with Kevin
McCarthy watching him work seeing how he
was doing it it was a remarkable he's
raised 480 million dollars he went out
and recruited this will be the most
diverse most inclusive house Republican
party in history they developed a
commitment to America that's much more
sophisticated than what we did with the
contract with America back in 94. so I I
really went into election night when
cliff and I went down to watch returns
with Kevin I felt really good until
webbian to realize there's something
missing here and I agree with you when I
saw the cook report which said as of
this morning that six million more votes
for Republicans I think as California
comes in it may slide down to 5 million
but still we get five or six million
more votes and we don't pick up a whole
bunch of seats we need to analyze that I
mean there's something going on out
there that we don't understand and
frankly a lot of the expert analysis
which was based on race the the races
are wrong when you start looking at the
votes so there's a lot to be to be
learned out of this but Kevin McCarthy I
can't wait for the moment where Pelosi
has to hand if she's still there Kevin
McCarthy the gavel and the degree to
which in committees in investigations
and scheduling things all of a sudden
you're in a totally different house you
know uh you know my kids are athletes a
win is a win and sometimes you win ugly
not with your best game and I'll take it
anyway uh Newt Gingrich thanks for being
with us hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else